MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
Well, hello everybody.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you for those
of you who aren't
in the room that are tuned in.
It's a particularly
exciting day today.
We have Janet Mock here with us.
And for those of you
who don't know Janet,
she is a New York Times
best selling author.
She is a trans advocate.
She is a GLAAD Award nominee.
The list goes on and on.
And we'll learn a lot more
about her as this goes on today.
So Janet, welcome.
Thank you very much for coming.
JANET MOCK: Thank
you for having me.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Totally.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
OK, so I thought
it would be fun to start with
some rapid fire questions.
JANET MOCK: Did you
introduce yourself?
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Oh, no.
I didn't.
OK, I will.
I'm Michael Bolognino.
I work at Google.
I do marketing for Google
Docs and thank you.
JANET MOCK: Yes, of course.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: All right.
Now that that's out of the way.
Your favorite New
York City season?
JANET MOCK: Spring.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
The fashion trend
that you hope is dead.
JANET MOCK: Fashion trend?
Uggs.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Yeah.
The favorite place that
you've been on vacation.
JANET MOCK: It has to
be going home to Hawaii.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
And the last place
you went on vacation?
JANET MOCK: Sarasota.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: All right.
Dogs or cats, or other?
JANET MOCK: Dogs.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK The
golden girl you most relate to?
JANET MOCK: Oh my god.
Sophia.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
A living person
that you haven't met,
that you dream to meet?
JANET MOCK: Hmm.
Toni Morrison.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
Do you have a current
TV show addiction?
JANET MOCK: Oh my
god, I'm trying
to figure out which ones-- I
just finished "True Detective,"
but I'm not obsessed with it.
But I think one of
those, like "Revenge,"
which is kind of a
bizarre obsession,
because it's like so
bad, but it's so good.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Totally.
JANET MOCK: You know?
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Yes.
OK.
Aretha Franklin
or Patti Labelle?
JANET MOCK: Patti.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
JANET MOCK: I saw that shade.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
Yeah that's what--
JANET MOCK: That
she threw at her.
She was like, I'm not
touching your hand.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: So you're
on the side with Patti's team?
JANET MOCK: Yes.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK, OK.
And for breakfast,
sweet or savory?
JANET MOCK: Sweet.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
And then your favorite
Janet Jackson album
that is not "The Velvet Rope."
JANET MOCK: "Control."
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
Excellent.
All right, now that that's out
of the way, let's talk about,
well things are super
exciting for you right now.
So before we talk about the
book itself, you've been,
obviously the New York Times
best seller just happened.
That's huge.
Personally, it was just your
birthday, so happy birthday.
JANET MOCK: Thank you.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: The
book's doing amazing.
What do you think
is the highlight
in the last few months
for you personally?
JANET MOCK: I think it's meeting
people around the country,
and kind of sharing
space and stories,
and intimacies with strangers.
Because I think that the
bizarre thing about writing
in a genre like memoir,
is that everyone
knows so much about
you, but you know
no one, nothing
about someone else.
And so I think that
there's this, especially
with just the platform
of books period,
there's such intimacy there.
You have to really engage with
it for long periods of time,
right?
It's not like an article
that you can skim real quick,
and kind of read the headline,
and maybe read the first two
paragraphs, and be
like, I really got that.
A book, you have to
really sit there with it,
and share space with it.
And I think a book as open as
mine is in terms of intimacy,
it builds this-- it's real.
It's an authentic
sense of intimacy.
But when you're sharing
space with people,
and you don't know
anything about them,
and they know so much
about you that they
can remember your best
friend from childhood,
and you're just like, OK.
And so hearing people
come back to me
and telling me about themselves,
writing letters to me,
telling me the points of
intersection, of resonance,
in the book with them
that struck them,
that's been the most
valuable, I think,
interactions and exchanges
post writing the book.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: I'm
sure there's a ton of that.
I mean, I know just sitting with
you earlier, we were already
hearing from lots of people
since we've been here.
So it's pretty incredible.
So let's talk about now the
process of writing the book.
So how did it start?
Are you a journaler,
what's your process?
JANET MOCK: It definitely
started through journals.
I think before it was
"Redefining Realness,"
it was just kind of
my daily thoughts
about stories from
my life and memories.
And so they weren't
really even stories yet.
The were just
fragments of memories
that I knew that I wanted
to like have a record of.
And so they were also informed
by my daily interactions
with self, meaning this is
before I stepped forward
in Marie Claire,
which I did in 2011,
and kind of tool
part of my story.
And so sitting
there telling myself
my own stories was a
way for me to, I guess,
strengthen myself a
little bit, and get ready
for public
consumption that comes
from the public space
of being visible.
And so it very much started
from daily journals.
At the time I was
reading something
called "The Artist's Way."
So I don't know if anyone
knows Julia Cameron's book,
but I was doing morning
pages faithfully.
And I was single at time, so
I had lots of time to myself.
So girl was navel
gazing for days.
And so it was very
much from that process.
And then it grew to not only
wanting to write my story,
but then talking to
people in my life.
My boyfriend who
came into my life
at the time, my best
friend, opening up to her.
Then the next level
was Marie Claire,
and then it was also
politicizing my experiences.
Well, contextualizing them
through a political and social
landscape, and really
making it more than just me.
So this memoir is
very much birthed out
of my process over the
last four or five years.
And then it finally
came forward.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK, now
that makes total sense.
And I think that for
me, reading the book,
the people that I encountered
were such a huge part
of the story, like
you said earlier.
And I remember you mentioning,
I think in the introduction
perhaps, that you
talked to a lot of them
before the book came out.
And so what is that like to have
a conversation with someone?
You deal with a lot of
challenging relationships
in the book.
So how does that-- was it
particularly hard for you
to talk about them in the book?
Just help us understand that
process of publicly telling
your story that
involves someone else.
JANET MOCK: I think for me,
my parents were fair game.
Because I did not
get to choose them,
so I felt like it
was a completely fair
for me to write very
openly about their lives
and their interactions with me.
My siblings felt a
little more shaky for me.
And so I think I felt the
most obligation, probably
to my brother Chad,
because he spent so much,
we were only a year
and 13 days apart,
so we were born very closely.
Our birthdays were always
celebrated very closely.
And so I felt the most
obligation and sensitivity
towards him.
And so that was a tricky
thing for me to navigate.
So that's why I think that
I spent a lot of time.
If I was going to write
about someone a lot,
I made sure that I had their
voice in the book a lot.
So I interviewed my mother.
I interviewed my father.
I interviewed my brother Chad,
and interviewed my best friend
Wendy.
And so those were the
four people that I felt
were very pivotal
characters in the book.
But it's weird to
say characters,
because they're actual people.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
Right, totally.
JANET MOCK: But for the
reader, it's a character,
because they don't
really know this person.
They know this person through
my lens, and experience,
and interactions with them.
And so yeah, the process of
writing about people, people
you love and care about,
is also a difficult thing.
But I think the one thing I
learned with memoir that it's
not so much a space
for venting or revenge.
It's a space to really look
at everyone in your life,
even yourself, with
the same brutal honesty
and sharp criticism
that you look
at, quote unquote, villains.
And so in this book, there's
no antagonists to me.
I think that everyone's a
full person in this book.
And I think that when you
communicate that kind of nuance
and complexity, it gives
a more true experience.
Like my parents,
my parents, if you
read "Redefining Realness,"
my parents for super messy,
and ill equipped, and
battled a drug addiction
and abusive relationship.
And both had tons of children
that they didn't really
have the resources
to take care of,
but I had to really look at how
they grew up, in the same sense
that I have to give
sensitivity to how I grew up.
And so when I can look at
my parents as more than just
these people who were my
mother and father, but as
their own people who
had their own struggles,
and failed expectations,
and heart breaks,
I could paint a
more full portrait.
And so I hoped to do that
with each character or person
in the book, in
which I wrote about.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
I definitely felt
like I got to know
them very well.
And that was one of the favorite
parts, for me, of the book.
So after it came out,
had your relationships,
have you sat down and
talked about the content
about particular people.
And how is that shaped,
has it strengthened or hurt
any of your relationships?
JANET MOCK: Wow.
I think that's the bizarre
part, is that my parents were
learning about me as the
world was learning about me.
Because I had never been
so open with them about it.
They're learning about their
child talking about sexuality,
talking about creating
a space for the erotic,
talking about what she was
doing with her body and the pain
that they caused
upon her, being me.
It was a memoir, so still have
a hard time with "I" statements.
So it's really bizarre.
So I think or my parents,
it was this weird sense of,
I'm really fascinated
by this story,
but this story is
like about my child.
And so I think
that's a weird space
to be in as a reader,
someone that's so invested.
The first person that
read the book in process
was my boyfriend Aaron.
And he was like, wow,
you really told it all.
And I think that
he also felt there
was this weird sense of Prince
Charming-esque abilities
that I threw onto him.
And he was like, this isn't
like necessarily true,
but I can see, you know?
For him, it's not how
he sees himself, right?
And so I think there's
this weird-- for him,
that's what he took
away from the book.
But he was like, oh wow, it
was really interesting to see
someone I love so
much, their full story
through their own perspective.
And I think it was the same
kind of thread with my parents.
Like I finally had a real depth
conversation with my father
three nights ago about the book.
I think it was very
difficult for him
to get through the book, because
so much of the first half of it
is about his struggles.
And I was writing about it from
my perspective as a six, seven,
eight, nine-year-old,
10-year-old.
And also his gender
policing of me as a child.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Let's
talk about that for a minute.
One of the elements
the book that I thought
was particularly intense,
or had to be hard for you,
was when he discovered your,
I guess, alter ego, Keisha.
And for those of you who
haven't read the book,
maybe you want to explain--
JANET MOCK: Yeah.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK, who
Keisha was, and then I'll
explain what
happened after that.
JANET MOCK: So Keisha was,
I invented her, I think,
when I was 10 years old.
So my father had many
different girlfriends
and they all had children.
And so this one apartment
that we settled in, there's
a teenage girl, she was about
15, and I was about, I think,
nine or 10.
And she would always talk
to boys on the phone.
And so she would use me to
tell them that she's not home,
to lie to them.
And so one day when she
actually wasn't home,
and there was this boy that
she was trying to avoid,
I was like like, oh, you
know, Mikaela's not here,
but this is Keisha, and
Mikaela told me to talk to you.
And so I was just kind of
telling these tall tales,
and fantasies, and stories of
my would be life as a girl.
Because I was perceived to be
a boy throughout my childhood.
And so at the time, being
this very feminine child who
didn't yet know
that she was trans,
I expressed my girlhood through
this character of Keisha,
which fell closer to me
than myself, even though I
knew that it was
very much a role.
And so Keisha
began on the phone,
and then Keisha went into real
life during my spring break
of like 1994, 1993 it was.
I just remember
"What A Man" was on.
And I really wanted to memorize
Salt 'N Pepa's "What A Man,"
which I did, by the way.
And I will not sing
any of it here.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: What
if we do it together?
JANET MOCK: No.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
JANET MOCK: So that's
a side note, tangent.
So I brought Keisha
out to the real world.
And my little cousin, Michelle,
who was like two years
younger than me, we went
out and I developed a crush
on a boy who really liked me.
And I had long curly
hair at the time.
And so, I was like,
oh, I'm Keisha.
We had this little
flirtation, very innocent.
And then one day, when my
father was picking me up
on the last day of spring
break, the boy, Jamie, knocks
on the door and
says, is Keisha here?
And then it creates
this whole thing
that you have to see play out.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Totally.
Well, my heart was racing with
yours when I read that part.
And so then what happens
next, essentially,
is that your dad
shaves your head.
And I think hair, to me,
seems like it represented
a way that you could
express yourself at a time
when you weren't quite sure how,
or what was OK or comfortable,
and it was very natural to you.
How did it feel?
And I imagine that
it really felt
like it stripped you
of that identity.
And then I know the
process of going back,
and the Gumby, someone called
you Gumby, or something?
Just tell me about that.
So what was your experience
after that with your dad?
JANET MOCK: So I think it was
the first time my father really
truly saw me.
I think he saw me before, but
it was easy for him to deny it,
because other people
didn't recognize or see.
So having this boy walk up
into his sister's space,
and to say, I'm looking for
Keisha, this girl, my father,
he needed to correct that.
And so for him, he, as you just
explained, he shaved my head.
And that was my only sense
of a physical embodiment
of my girlhood at the
time, of my true identity
as how I knew myself.
And so my father, doing that, he
thought that he was erasing it.
But hair does grow
back, even though it
was very traumatic at the time.
And I had to really go through
it for a year and a half.
And I think that is was
just this moment where
he was very confused, and he was
battling himself, and battling
his own ideas of what gender is,
and what his role as a father
was, to raise this child
that he saw as his son that
was his namesake, and
all these kind of things.
And so I think
that it is symbolic
of a lot of our
interactions growing up.
And you see there's
these little moments
and he even threatens me, years
before that, he'll cut my hair.
It was always the big threat.
And so when he actually
followed through on that,
I think it was a major
pivot in our relationship.
And I think it's great
that a year and a half
later, I basically move
with my mother to Hawaii,
and it's a completely
different environment.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Right, OK.
JANET MOCK: It also shows also
the agency of young people,
the lack of agency
often in most homes,
where you don't have control
over having the resources
and funds to buy
your own clothes,
to say that you want to do what
you want and express yourself
in dress, in hair, in makeup
or adornments in any way.
And so a lot of
times your parents
are very much, at least in the
households that I grew up in,
it was very much, we
have $150 allotted to you
at the beginning
of the school year.
And we're not giving you $150,
we're going with you to shop.
And so for me was
always this pained time.
It was like, oh shit, I have to
wear all these damn JC Penney
polos, and all this
stuff, cargo shorts.
And it's like, oh
lord, and I have
to wear the stuff, because I
have no agency to say that, no,
and even no voice really to say
that I don't feel comfortable
in these clothes.
And this is not
what I want to wear,
and I didn't feel that
safety in both of my homes
to do that until I was maybe
like 13 or 14 years old.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Right.
Well, I guess that's
almost near the point
where you met Wendy, right?
JANET MOCK: Mmm hmm.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: And I think
you guys together found ways
to grab that agency, and started
buying the clothes that you
wanted to buy, right?
And so tell us a little
bit about that inflection
point in your life.
JANET MOCK: Yeah,
that relationship, I
think it's one of those
things where some people just
come into your life
at certain times.
You don't know why.
And so Wendy was just
someone who really saw me.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: She saw
you first at school, right?
JANET MOCK: Yes, she
saw me at school.
I was picking up my
brother from school.
We were waiting for
my mom to pick us up
from the little playground
that's between our two schools.
I was middle school, I
was in the seventh grade.
And my brother Jeffrey
was six years younger,
so he was in the first grade.
And he was just playing, and
I was sitting on the swings.
And Wendy was walking by with
her green bob and her high,
her super short shorts,
soccer shorts rolled up,
and her knee high socks.
And she just passed by
with her volleyball,
and she was like,
Mary, are you mahu?
And I was just like,
I didn't say anything,
because I wasn't ready for
that sense of reflection
and recognition, like
she really saw me.
And mahu is, I was in
Honolulu at the time,
so mahu is this--
it's kind of a term,
it's like a third
space for gender
beyond the gender binary,
beyond male and female.
There's a space to
explore the spectrum.
But it mostly was
applied loosely,
if you bring the Western
colonized sense of what mahu
is, it's loosely
termed as transgender.
But that's not
really what it is,
but it's kind of a space
outside of male-female.
And it's oftentimes
for children that
are assigned male
at birth, based
on the appearance
of their genitals,
and who are feminine presenting.
And so when Wendy saw
me, that's what she saw,
even though I was wearing
these polos from JC Penney.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
She clocked you.
JANET MOCK: Yeah, she
basically clocked me.
She spooked me.
She was like, girl, I see you.
Why are you trying to pretend?
And I just ignored her.
And so I was not
ready for her yet.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Right.
And here she is, so visible.
JANET MOCK: Yes.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: So green.
JANET MOCK: Yes, and
looking for friends,
and looking for like,
girl, I see you,
I'm going to come
follow up later on.
And she did.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: So
when she followed up,
what did you ready
to talk to her?
JANET MOCK: I think growing
up in a home where I always
had this dream
image of my mother,
you have to really break
down the family chronology.
My parents met.
A year later, they got
married, and had me.
And they already had children
from previous relationships.
And they were fairly young,
they were 23 years old.
And my mother already
had two girls before.
And my father had three
children from high school.
Messy.
And so then I come along, the
embodiment of what they believe
is going to be
their life together,
their first marriages.
They're going to fulfill
the American dream.
And he was a Navy
officer, and she
was this woman who
worked in Honolulu,
and he's this black
man from Dallas, Texas.
And they meet.
That does not work out, because
of my father's philandering
ways and my mother's just too
high expectations from someone
that she's not fully seeing.
And the so they break
up when I'm about three.
Me and my brother go and
live with my parents,
live with my mother in Honolulu.
We stay with her for
a couple of years,
then she sends us, because
we need mail influences,
her sons need male influences.
So she sends us to live
with my father, who
I live with for six
years, five to six years.
In that time, I don't
see my mother at all.
And my parents both have
the same parenting style,
which is, out of
sight, out of mind.
And so I dreamt of my mother.
I had these huge streams
of who I thought she was.
They were Disney prone,
and very way too much
imaginings of this
dream girl in my life.
And so when I went
back to Hawaii,
I thought I was going to
be the perfect son for her,
and butch up, and Wendy
is like, girl, no.
That's not true.
I'm looking at you, and
I don't see that anymore.
And so I was like I'm going to
hold onto it for a little bit
more for my mother.
Right?
Because I think as children,
that's what we internalize.
If we do the right
things, if we are perfect,
our parents will truly see us,
and love us, and except us,
and give us everything
that we want.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: I
want to actually, I
remember-- sorry
to interrupt you,
but I remember seeing that work
that you did so well at school.
And that kind of pride,
I think, is in line
with what you're saying.
That's part of being the perfect
child, is studying and getting
good grades.
JANET MOCK: Oh yeah, for sure.
And so I think that I really
began, and within that year,
I began really seeing my
mother for who she was.
She was no longer this
dream girl image of her.
She was herself.
And I think it did not
live up to my-- no one
can live up to the
expectations you
have in your head of someone.
And so for my mother,
there's a sense
that she failed me,
in my childlike mind,
in my adolescent mind.
And so I decided to just
be myself after a while.
And I was like, this pretending
to be someone else for her
is not working for me anymore.
And so that's when I
accepted Wendy's invitations
of friendship.
And that's when we begin
going to the thrift store,
and pulling stunts
in the thrift store,
and changing price tags for
like the color coded tag sales.
Sometimes when you go,
it's like, the blue tags
are 50% off.
And so we were very much
scheming, and going in,
it was a mess.
But it was great.
You know what I mean?
It was how we found agency with
having very little resources.
We could go in with $10
to $15, and leave what
tons of little soccer
shorts, and high socks,
and shoulder pads for hip
pads, and all these kind
of little things that
we ended up doing.
We carved out our own space
for womanhood together.
We developed that together.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Yeah.
And she's still in
your life, right?
JANET MOCK: Yeah, she's
still my closest friend.
I think it's very interesting.
We've had points when our lives
went in separate directions
at certain points.
I kind of write about it.
And when we came back
to, in adulthood,
really seeing each
other again, it's
so great to have that
shared history with someone.
But that history also
breeds so much intimacy.
Because there's
nothing that I've ever
had to explain
anything to Wendy.
She just always has
seen me, and known me,
and affirmed me, and
validated me, and also
nurtured me as a friend.
And I always think of
sisterhood, and just good
friendships, and any
kind of relationships,
whether they're
romantic, or platonic,
or sisters, or
brothers, or siblings.
That's the kind of relationship
she's always had for me.
And I think of what
a blessing that
was, for me to be a 12-year-old
to find that friendship,
and then to develop
it and still have it
now as a 30 something
year old person.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Totally.
So in addition to the
people in your life,
another theme that I saw come
through was music as something
that you turned to.
You already mentioned
"What A Man."
But I read about Aaliyah, and
I read about Toni Braxton,
and the list goes on.
I'm actually curious, who do you
think, in today's music world,
would be the equivalent for
a trans girl to look up to
or [INAUDIBLE].
JANET MOCK: I think pop
culture's so personal.
So I think it's hard to say.
I think some, obviously trans
girls, we're not all the same,
so we would all like
different kinds of music.
Some may be into punk.
That's not my thing.
You know what I mean?
So I think for me, I was
very Pop R&B oriented.
So that's why when Destiny's
Child came out with "No, No,
No," "Bills, Bills, Bills," and
"Say My Name," and "Independent
Woman," that was my life.
I basically have a
whole chapter dedicated
to my love of Destiny's
Child and Beyonce.
Because it just shows how
media representations,
seeing yourself in media,
and someone else whose
experiences are completely
different than yours,
but who just has something
that resonates with you.
And I think that for all of
us, that's very personal.
But I think that
for me, I wanted
to not only be literary
in my references,
because I talk about spending
a lot of time in libraries,
and reading books by a
lot of women of color,
like Toni Morrison
and Alice Walker,
but also these media
representations of Beyonce,
and Oprah Winfrey,
and Diana Ross.
And all of these
women just kind of
give me this whole composite
of self that really showed me.
So I think that's very personal,
but it's also very shared too.
I think we talked a
little bit about some
of the points of pop culture--
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Yes.
JANET MOCK: Resonance for us.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Totally.
Exactly.
So have you encountered
any of these women
since your book's come out?
Has there been any
kind of crossover,
or have you met any of them?
JANET MOCK: No, not yet.
Not yet, Beyonce.
I've not met Beyonce.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: This is your
chance to make an invitation.
OK.
All right, so I think we're
getting a little bit close.
I have a few more things
that we could talk about,
and then we'll open
it up for questions.
So I want to talk
a little bit about
your #GirlsLikeUs campaign.
So tell us a little bit
about where that started,
and where it's at today.
JANET MOCK: So it started
specifically on Twitter
at first.
And so it was a hashtag
of solidarity and space
to share resources,
stories, experiences,
and conversations
between trans women.
And I started it in March
2012, and since then it's gone
on to, of course,
Google+, and Facebook,
and everywhere where
you can do hash tags.
And so Tumblr, you'll
see a space for it,
and Instagram, and all
these different spaces.
So it's kind of like the
social media campaign
to claim space, in virtual
space, which nowadays
is kind of real life space,
for trans women in a world
where trans women,
often it's not safe
for them to leave their homes.
I mean, I think that
that's something
that people don't often realize.
These social media
platforms can be a lifeline
for a lot of people who are
struggling with identity, who
are struggling with self,
who don't have validation,
and affirmation, and
real life friendships.
Because my experience
is very bizarre
that I grew up with
a trans girlfriend.
My best friend was trans.
I didn't grow up in isolation.
But most trans women
grow up in isolation.
They're often the only ones.
And so to have a space
for young, and poor,
and all these different kinds
of trans women to come together
and say, you know what, in this
space, on Twitter, on Facebook,
on Google+, we can have a space
that's our own that we can go
to for a source of mirroring,
and reflections, and sharing,
and sisterhood.
That's what
#GirlsLikeUs has always
been for me and my idea
of what I want it to be.
I don't know where
I'm taking it yet,
because I feel like there's
just so much going on.
But I would like it to still,
I think that for me, it
would be creating a
real life space for it.
I think that it is
still like, #GirlsLikeUs
as a name, and a brand, is
something that I want to have,
maybe for like a summer
camp for young trans girls.
That would be my
legacy project that I
would love to do with it.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Great.
OK.
And then, I guess,
one more question.
So it seems like lately, even
the last couple of weeks,
trans visibility is
popping up in the media
perhaps more than I
have seen it previously.
You were featured in the
New York Times article
last week alongside a
lot of other trans folks,
we've got to Laverne Cox in
"Orange Is The New Black."
Do you feel like there's some
kind of turning point brewing?
What do you think is next?
What has to happen next?
JANET MOCK: I think
what has to happen
next, is actions of
true inclusivity,
meaning that trans people
are not these objects
to be gawked at, and
kind of say, look
at these trans
superstars, right,
that's a separate thing from us.
I think they really need to
have more and more spaces.
I think one that I
would like to applaud,
that I was lucky enough to
be a part of, and humbled
to be a part of, was the
Women's History Month Google
Doodle, which included two
trans women of color in it,
an Asian American
trans woman and myself.
And that's the kind
of actions that really
need to be happening, I
think, in media platforms,
to really think about the
points of intersection which,
trans women for me, trans
women are kind of how I center
a lot of my politic,
how we can include
trans women in their
different intersections
in a lot of these spaces.
Because trans issues are
not its own separate issues,
it's a human issue.
We all have a
sexual orientation,
we all have a gender identity.
And we really break
it down in that way.
We see people as more complex,
more across the spectrum
of just speaking
across difference.
So for me, I would love
for a big media moment
to really happen, where a
media platform takes leadership
in really sparking
a conversation.
Say, like a Time
Magazine creating a cover
to say that this is the
next civil rights movement.
This is something that we really
need to begin talking about.
Because a lot of people
do it as trend pieces,
like, trans people are
having a moment now.
And for me, my entire
life, trans people
have been having moments.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Right.
JANET MOCK: It's just like, you
decided to pay attention now?
But we've been having
moments forever.
Christine Jorgensen
was around in the '50s.
And Carolyn Cossey was
around in the '80s and '90s
on the Arsenio Hall Show.
So none of this stuff is new.
It's kind of
cyclical, and I think
it's just media that says
that, oh, this is hot now.
And so I think our culture
is ready to develop language
and to really discuss
discourse with trans people
about their actual
lives, and not
so much about what they
do to their bodies,
because that's been
tried and true and done.
So I think that a lot of
the reason why there's
been a lot of discourse lately
is because trans women have
been at a point to say that
the way that you're reporting
on my life is not cute anymore.
And so this is why there's
an issue with this,
and why it's reductive, and why
it's not enough, and that yes,
you need to see us as people.
I am a woman, and
that's who I am.
I happen to be trans,
and happen to be black.
But all of these things
are part of my experience,
and if you really want
to engage with me,
please read my book first and
then bring me on your show.
Hashtag #ShadyQueen.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: OK.
This has been really great.
I could keep talking to
you for hours, but I won't.
So does anyone here in the
room have any questions?
Oh yeah, please
use the microphone
so the people on the
live stream can hear.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I don't really have a
question, but I just
wanted to thank you for being
willing to be in the spotlight.
JANET MOCK: Oh,
thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Very helpful.
JANET MOCK: Thank you,
I appreciate that.
AUDIENCE: I was just
thinking about how
you're talking about being
seen for who you really are.
Do you feel like it's
been difficult for people
to see who you are?
Have you become
very good at seeing
other people for
who they really are?
Or is that difficult
for you too?
JANET MOCK: I think I
can only truly see people
if they allow me to share
space with their experiences
and stories.
So for me, what I've learned
in this entire process of being
very visible is not
to make assumptions
about people's identities,
or lives, or pains,
or points of access, or
exile and oppression.
And so for me, I
think there's only so
much you can tell about a
person by just looking at them.
So for me, I think
that as a trans
person, as a person of
color, as a woman of color,
I don't make assumptions about
people anymore just based
on my vain
interaction with them,
or how I may perceive them.
And so that's the
one thing that I
think that I wish
that we all should do.
So that's why I appreciate when
there's points of conversation
in group settings when we say
that, what are your pronouns?
You announce those
things, so that we
don't assume what someone's
gender is, because you never
know just based on
looking on people.
But I think that we've
grown up in a culture where
we just kind of assume people's
identities and genders.
And that's not necessarily
something we should do anymore.
And I hope that that's what
these conversations kind of
spark and bring up.
In terms of myself, I
find that oftentimes I'm
invited to spaces
and only expected
to speak about being
trans, whereas I think
that my experience is so
much more than just transes.
Not that speaking
about transes alone
is something that I shy away
from or anything like that.
But I'm also a
woman of color, I'm
also someone that grew up poor.
I'm also someone that, as a
teenager, engaged in sex work
because I don't have
resources to have health care.
And all these
different things that I
think that I can speak to,
but I'm not really brought
to the table to
speak about that.
They're like, hey,
young woman, we just
want to talk about
being trans right now,
as if that's my only experience.
And most times when
I navigate the world,
most people don't
know I'm trans.
They often take me for a
cisgendered mixed black woman,
and what does that mean to
be that kind of a woman,
someone that's objectified
in the streets,
and all these kind of different
points of intersection.
And so I hope that we can
have deeper conversations
about people's
identities, and what
their lives and lived
experiences are actually like.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
Actually, could you
define cisgender for these
people who aren't familiar?
JANET MOCK: Sure.
Well, so there's trans.
I think most people
understand what trans is.
And cis this kind of the
opposite in terms of a prefix.
So trans means to
cross, and cis,
it's kind of like chemistry
terms, which is interesting.
But this is really getting
inside baseball a little bit.
I don't even know
what that means.
I just often say
that, inside baseball,
because I don't
even watch sports.
But cis means on
the same side of,
and so when you're talking
about cisgendered, or cissexual,
transgender or transsexual,
trans often means to cross,
and cis means to stay
on the same side of.
So often we're talking
about relationships
with your assigned sex at
birth, which we are all
based on the way that
our genitals may look.
When we're born
as babies, you're
assigned a sex, which is often
different from your gender
expression.
And so for cis people, they
often times, most likely,
identify with the sex
and gender that they
were assigned with that birth.
So they stay on
the same side of,
whereas trans people cross
that, or are perceived
to cross some kind
of invisible barrier
that we have in our culture
about gender and sex,
and sex that's
assigned at birth.
So I hope that
explained that well.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO:
Yeah, thank you OK,
are there any other
questions from the room?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
JANET MOCK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: First off,
thank you for being here.
This has been really
great to watch.
JANET MOCK: Thank
you for coming.
AUDIENCE: There's this idea in
the gay world of guys or girls
who can pass.
Guys might be
masculine, or might not
look like the
stereotypical image of what
a homosexual looks
like to society.
JANET MOCK: Whatever that means.
AUDIENCE: Whatever that means.
But what it means
in day to day life
is that they have
to keep coming out
in the workplace with new
colleagues, with new friends,
they keep saying, hey, I'm gay,
by the way, this is who I am,
because you can't tell.
Do you feel you need to keep
coming out in your life?
And maybe now it's
a little different
because you're in the spotlight.
But in general, do
you feel like you
have to keep coming
out about who you are?
Is that tiring for you?
And do you ever just
want to be a young woman
and live, and not have to keep
explaining who you are in life?
JANET MOCK: So for me, I
think that I write something.
That's a really
great question, I
think that what
we're talking about
is also gender expectations.
And I think that's
the link between trans
and lesbian, gay,
bisexual people,
is this idea of
gender expectations.
So if you're assigned
male at birth,
and you're attracted to men,
that's not following the gender
prescriptions that we prescribe
in our culture, right?
And so oftentimes that means
that to be a gay man that
is feminine presenting, then
people go, oh yeah, he's gay.
Whereas you can be a
completely straight man
and also be feminine
presenting, but we're
talking about gender
expectations, right?
So when you say a man who
isn't seen as homosexual,
and has to continue to come out
because he presents in a more
traditionally masculine way,
even though he's attracted
to men, which often is
prescribed as something
that women do, not
necessarily men,
which is very simplistic, right?
And so for me, I do
have trouble with that.
And I come out, and I
disclose my identity
as a trans woman for
political reasons.
Often in my personal
life, I don't.
It's not something that
I do every single day.
I don't feel like it's people's
right to know my story,
that my story is mine
to tell in spaces
of intimacy and relationship.
And if I feel like telling
someone, then I do.
But I never felt
an obligation to.
Often in public spaces I do, if
the context is to talk about,
or to place me
sometimes as trans.
So it's like, so why are you in
this LGBT space with this man,
because you look like
a straight woman.
Well, I am a straight woman,
but I am a trans woman.
And so it's really unpacking
that for people oftentimes.
But I don't feel an obligation.
Politically, I do.
And so I think that coming
out or inviting people
into your life is a
politicized movement
that we all do in
our personal lives.
And I choose to do that in
certain strategic spaces,
but oftentimes I don't
feel the obligation to.
Yeah.
Thank you.
MICHAEL BOLOGNINO: Thank you.
All right, it doesn't look
like there are other questions,
so I want to thank you,
Janet, again for coming.
I want to let everyone know
that "Redefining Realness" is
available everywhere
books are sold.
And I encourage you to read it.
I read it twice.
It's excellent.
So thanks again,
Janet, for coming.
JANET MOCK: Thank
you for having me.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]